le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais dans notre
quotidien
il n'est pas rare de croiser des
personnes porteuses de handicap
elles sont 38 milles à la réunion que
leur handicap soit physique ou mentale
ces personnes font leur maximum pour
s'intégrer au fonctionnement de la
société
cependant comment facilitons nous leur
vie quels sont les moyens mis en oeuvre
pour les aider
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
farid est un jeune artiste qui veut
s'imposer dans le monde de la musique
réunionnaise porteurs de handicap
il nous explique que les portes des
studios se ferment régulièrement devant
lui mon objectif dans la vie c'est de
déjà deux réussis en musicalement de
devenir chanteur professionnel et aussi
en parallèle devenir aussi infographiste
dans le cadre de mon handicap je n'ai
jamais eu de souci particulier qu'ils
soient dans ma vie personnelle
professionnelle mais dans le cas de
musicale oui ça m'a toujours posé un
problème car on n'est pas souvent
acceptées prise au sérieux on est
handicapé en commentant des jeunes
artistes
c'est pour ça aussi fait appel aussi à
tous les gens à tous les boîtes de
production de boîtes de nuit de
manifestants pour tous qui dit
manifestation scène et tous d'essayer de
d'ouvrir la scène à tout le monde et
décidé d'arrêter aussi de regarder le
côté anti cas car malgré un handicap on
ne chante pas avec le fauteuil mais avec
sa bouche
afin d'éveiller les consciences et
permettre aux personnes handicapées de
découvrir les différents moyens mis en
place par le conseil général le 1er juin
au jardin de l'état se tiendra la 2e
journée départementale de la personne
handicapée
une journée pour tous accessible à tous
et pleine de surprises
une journée placée notamment sous le
signe de l'art et de la culture
farid lui aussi sera de la partie et
vous fera découvrir son talent et ses
compositions dans le cadre du conseil
général j'ai été invité le premier
adjoint à une manifestation jardin de
l'état qui va se dérouler avec la
reproduction
un concert d'une heure c'est ma avec
plein d'artistes comme lise en j ai
encore plein d'autres encore qui
participe aussi sur cet album là je
repars avait accompagné aussi de mon dj
dj ryan qui est aussi mon manager aussi
actuellement dans ce cas de la madame
nassimah dindar n'a invité justement à
partager ma musique avec toutes les
personnes qui seront au rendez vous le
1er juin au jardin de l'état pour
nassimah dabach ainsi que pour
l'ensemble du conseil général il est
vital que chacun trouve sa place à la
réunion
les moyens mis en place par la
présidente et ses équipes sont
considérables environ 180 millions
d'euros par an entre adaptation des
infrastructures moyens pour permettre
l'accessibilité et dispositifs divers
par exemple les personnes handicapées
peuvent se rendre dans les musées gérés
par le conseil général sans que leur
handicap soit un frein le conseil
général nous continuerons à accompagner
les personnes porteuses de handicap pour
une accessibilité aux loisirs
le pass loisirs leur a permis nos
équipements culturels seront également
accessibles aux personnes porteuses de
handicap et beaucoup comme farid peuvent
aujourd'hui non seulement se mettre à la
musique mais également à l'art à la
sculpture à la peinture et je crois
qu'il faut non seulement aider
à cette démocratisation de la culture
pour tous mais c'est également un
enrichissement pour chacun d'entre nous
que d'écouter ces jeunes talents
nouveaux à découvrir à renouveler et je
souhaite à toutes les personnes qui
veulent aujourd'hui faire de la musique
de la photo peindre de venir au conseil
général dans des équipements à
l'artothèque à la bibliothèque
départementale faire en sorte qu' on
puisse faire émerger de nouveaux talents
j'ai un conseil à donner à toutes les
personnes qui sont différents handicaps
ou pas de croire et d'avancer de
justement de pas se laisser abattre au
premier parole des gens j'ai commencé la
musique exactement à l'âge de 10 ans
j'ai eu l'aide de monsieur nasser dudit
et de marica social du centre
d'éducation motrice au sein fusée qui
m'ont ouvert les portes qui m'ont permis
de faire pas mal de concerts hors du
département comme le grand festival
d'avignon en 2012 avec disney channel
talents et pas mal d'encre aux
manifestations pour vous dire que
l'handicap n'a jamais été un frein pour
personne encore moins pour les gens qui
souhaitent vraiment se battre dans le
milieu musical c'est juste une question
d'envié de motivation
moi je vous conseille de croix et
d'avancer sans réfléchir
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais